vincent jay d'infos là qui vient de mes
temps là par un producteur que j'adore
franck saurat d'un producteur
exceptionnel que j'aime dis moi que tu
aurais pas été disque d'or en trois
semaines toi c'est ça disque d'or en 3
public
c'est grâce au public mais c'est grâce
au public mais c'est aussi grâce à toi
parce que pas de voie publique est
grosse grâce à mes amis les bêtes c'est
vrai c'est qu'ils sont très forts en
cela ouais mais en fait j'étais chez moi
je vais la télé en fond et je les ai
entendues j'y ai pas vu d'abord
[Musique]
j'ai entendu donnant leur voix je me
suis retournée c'est là que j'ai vu
c'était des prêtres d'accord elle avait
raison qui dit quand elle parlait
justement des prêts dans la musique
aujourd'hui la famille le faire voilà
par exemple le rôle de la musique
classique un peu un peu christique comme
ça ça a beaucoup de succès mieux qu'à
des minutes non
[Musique]
douze mois passés en pardon sais c'est
que on avait un truc prévu qui est pas
arrivée du tout comme prévu
[Rires]
déjà on est dans quelle émission parce
que sur le retour je t'ai vu dans pas
mal de missions à l'heure les boîtes des
boîtes c'est moi d'accord écoute je suis
venu juste dire que cette danse là on a
créé pendant la grossesse à ryadh c'est
un truc de fou c'est la réponse à notre
souffrance du moment où il ya trop de
débats on va arrêter de parler de tout
on va juste dans ses envois
à
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
je serai là et n'ont été pour les
cadeaux que t'a offert à tous les gamins
à l'association same as gt gt bord de
renault étaient borderline je t'aime
et aussi je t'aime bien à ton fils très
bon anniversaire en remercie c'est
aujourd'hui mon petit il a 7 ans elle
arrivait justement
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le premier numéro ce soir et je pense
que vous allez kiffer maire c'est une
émission je vous lis et 100% agitation
on va pas se mentir c'est de l'agitation
donc tous dans tous les sens très mal et
les chérubins sont nico qui va animer
aussi le 24 décembre
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
tiens
peut-être
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
4 que je kiffe le problème c'est qu'il
entend cette musique j'ai envie de
lancer un truc ça franchement non je
vais d'abord te dire une chose
toi tu sais pourquoi je fais tout ça
parce que tu aimes la danse non parce
que tu aimes la vie
non parce que parce que j'ai du temps ce
même jour que c'est une idée dimanche
cela donne tu m'as aussi adressé à moi
en fait je trouve que cette musique ça
serait un peu la musique contre lara
sera ouais j'ai envie qu'on propose un
truc
ouais franchement aux gens
téléspectateurs c'est que on peut faire
garder baba atom
c'est à dire que on pourrait passer
comme ça fait chier les gens jose avant
de lancer un truc bien sa colère en
qu'il manque au mans c'est vrai c'est
que 7,7 vans être un ban avec un public
c'est un gars avec cela
tu fais quoi ta ce choix je suis dans
l'agro ce chan ok ça se voit
acteur on s'en parle elle est là
[Rires]
toujours là